and welcome to hannity
americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 44.
americans held hostage 44 days behind
enemy lines no light in sight for them
to get out hundreds of americans legal
residents with green cards have the
right to be here all of their families
thousands of our afghan allies yup they
remain abandoned behind enemy lines joe
biden has turned the page we will not
forget
sadly the situation on the ground it
gets worse every single day taliban
terrorists are now once again hanging
people in the public square but they're
doing it very professionally and
business-like according to the bite
administration including one man who has
reportedly strung up from a tall crane
right in the middle of the city
professional business-like we've turned
the page as we speak anyone who assisted
the u.s in any way is being hunted down
and will soon face a similar fate sadly
joe biden is not working at all to lift
a finger to rescue our fellow citizens
in fact he's barely working in on
anything at all last week four days on
the job jets off to camp david another
restful weekend today they call a lit at
2 48 p.m in the afternoon after refusing
to answer any questions about
afghanistan the crisis at our southern
border begging opec for more oil
production you know the usual things
that he ignores or the horrific state of
the economy take a look
let's just leave everybody into this
week
well it may not be by the end of the
week i hope it's by the end of the week
but as long as we're still alive we've
got three things to do
the debt ceiling
continued resolution
and the two pieces of legislation we do
that the country's going to be in great
shape
as you have these calls
mr president
this walks off you know like a robot
he's not allowed to answer questions he
gets yelled at and tonight instead of
addressing the crisis at the border the
byte administration they are outright
lying deflecting hoping the crisis will
magically resolve itself like
afghanistan we just won't pay attention
anymore joe biden thinks he did a great
job in afghanistan he did not the same
with the border for example in march
biden's homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas proclaimed the border
was closed and he said quote we are
expelling families we are expelling
single adults he was lying to you the
american people the following months
more than a million and a half illegal
immigrants have poured across that
border illegally and of course mayorkas
refuses to even now use the term illegal
alien or illegal immigrant instead he
calls them undocumented non-citizens
keyword non-citizens
for months now these undocumented
non-citizens or illegal immigrants or
aliens have been dispersed all over the
u.s with little to no vetting for
example almost everyone in the recent
wave of haitian migrants they were
admitted into the u.s with without so
much as a simple covid test because
they're not going to be here very long
that would be another lie take a look
how many have been released into the u.s
uh they're released on conditions and
approximately i think it's about 10
000 or so twelve thousand have been
released yes and of the five thousand
that are still in process
we will uh make determinations whether
they will be uh returned uh to uh haiti
uh based on our public health and public
interest uh authorities
so are we talking about a total of 12
000 or could it be even higher it could
it could be even higher the number that
a return could be even higher
i want to be clear about one thing i'm
actually a hundred percent on pro legal
immigration all four of my grandparents
they came here from ireland like so many
immigrants they were dirt poor both my
parents grew up with next to nothing
irish catholics they faced
discrimination at the time and i knew i
know i stand on their shoulders and i'm
grateful now if you're an immigrant i'll
be very honest i don't care what country
you come from what continent you come
from i don't care what you sound like
what you look like we're all god's
children but no country on earth is
without borders people have got to
respect our laws our borders and our
sovereignty period no exceptions
we must be a nation of laws in fact most
countries have very strict immigration
laws look at this in australia asylum
seekers they're not even allowed on
shore they will stop you and they will
take you to a camp in a different island
they'll give you food and water and
medical assistance if you need it and
then they'll send you home it is so
difficult for these refugees to
ultimately immigrate to australia that
the u.s they've been resettling
australian-bound migrants stuck in
offshore asylum camps near australia's
mainland they refused to take illegal
immigrants they uphold the law in their
country meanwhile in western europe you
have a record high 21 000 asylum seekers
in 2015. denmark they said enough's
enough then they took steps to stop and
process migrants again offshore and many
other countries you know citizenship is
such of high a high worth immigrants
will pay and purchase citizenship by the
way some americans they give up their
citizenship and buy citizenship in other
countries because why citizenship
especially to this country is of great
value for people coming from countries
that do not have the freedoms we often
take for granted you look at st lucia
for example it's roughly about 250 grand
you can get a passport and be a citizen
dominica the price tag is a hundred
thousand per passport antigua uh barbuda
yeah it's about a little over 134 grand
cyprus is asking a whopping two and a
half million they call them donations
and investments and you can buy
citizenship in new zealand you've got to
invest two million dollars over four
years and be there x number of days
malta it's 1.1 million in investments
and donations uh even canadian residency
you can purchase residency for a few
hundred thousand bucks worth of
government bonds citizenship is a
valuable coveted thing all around the
globe america the greatest country in
the world how much would people pay
to be a citizen here maybe we should
also get in on this action and maybe
charge people to be citizens every other
country appears to be doing it here in
the u.s where we let in more immigrants
than anywhere else on earth we don't ask
for a penny instead in theory we merely
ask immigrants to follow our laws and we
need to do more for example i don't care
where you come from everybody coming
into this country should undergo a
security vetting to make sure you don't
have radical associations in the middle
of a pandemic it would be a pretty wise
thing to make sure we do a health
vetting so you're not covert positive or
don't have any other disease in most
cases immigrants also should prove they
have the ability if we're generous
enough to invite them in
that they have to be able to take care
of themselves financially not be a
burden on the american people we cannot
put that burden we can't afford to put
that burden on the american people
ideally they would also possess a
coveted skill or a trade we can't drive
the wages of american workers down
either unfortunately democrats block
donald trump's merit-based immigration
bill like they have in countries like
australia now joe biden is refusing to
enforce any of our existing immigration
laws he's not only enforcing the laws
he's aiding and abetting the law
breaking which he swore not to do
no background checks no health checks
many are a huge financial burden to you
the american taxpayer we just can't
afford
joe biden's open borders and his
lawlessness our southern border is a
free for all he's made it that way the
administration doesn't know exactly who
they're letting in just a future
requested court date that's a requested
court date they don't even require you
to appear now under joe biden in other
words most immigrants they're not going
to they're not going to abide by the
request they don't have to
this has massive security implications
and as once uh the once lucid joe biden
stated in 2007 much different joe biden
than we see today no country can be
secure without controlling their borders
let's listen to joe back in the good old
days
what do i think about
the control of our borders what would i
do about it
ladies and gentlemen no great country
can say it is secure
without being able to control its
borders
period
what i would do about it was that i
proposed to do about it
almost 13 years ago
i would radically ramp up
the number of border security guards we
have
the use of electronic surveillance
material we have to guard the border
and a number of what they call virtual
fences
that joe biden we see today looks pretty
weak frail and is a cognitive mess in
comparison isn't he but that's a
sideshow unfortunately biden now cares
less about a secure america and more
about the radical socialist base that is
the modern democratic socialist party
because that's socialist based they
don't believe in borders uh and whether
they put any value on it they want a
complete unfettered immigration no
matter what now
why ask yourself the democrats they try
to sneak amnesty into the senate
reconciliation bill
uh free citizenship until the senate
parliamentarian stepped in uh that's
something of great value for democrats
is it their hope that oh we're gonna
give you something that other countries
charge hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars for we'll give it to
you but you're going to vote democrat
right and you're not going to vote for
those meno republicans that follow the
law and believe that you should respect
our law and our sovereignty and our
borders you're not going to vote for
them i don't care where you come from
just do illegally forget that mass
migration drives down wages for
low-income workers forget the health and
security implications in the middle of a
pandemic forget uh the abuse the rape
the human trafficking that goes on
during these massive caravans through
mexico and other countries forget the
mass migration drives down all of these
wages etc etc you know all of this you
know is done again and again and again
and joe biden has no clue apparently
none of these things matter to the
radical left so instead of securing the
border and telling migrants not to come
biden is deflecting he's lying and he's
blaming everyone else especially donald
trump blaming the border patrol agents
on horseback falsely accusing them of
whipping migrants even the photographer
that took the picture said that didn't
happen that is a lie now the border
patrol union the agents are fighting
back and they're demanding an apology
he's blaming congress for not passing
comprehensive immigration reform joe
you're the president you get it done you
have both houses of congress and your
party runs the whole show that's also a
lie donald trump controlled the borders
we had what a 40-year low of illegal
immigrants why because he put in place
measures like building a border wall
stay in mexico policy ending catch and
release which you have now turned into
process and release all of this and more
biden is also blaming trump for directly
handing him a god-awful mess at the
border no he actually handed you secure
borders he also handed you energy
independence he also handed you a world
that was secure an afghanistan that was
secure and joe even blamed the weather
claiming that the migrant surge was
seasonal and would end during the summer
months that actually got worse and i can
report the migrant surge didn't end
during the summer it continues this day
august 200 000 people alone